hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I'm just checking it on you how are you
everybody how was your holiday whatever
you celebrate oh Hanukkah and Christmas
and Kwanzaa - what do you believe
[Music]
[ __ ] polar bears don't give up on
them boo hoo hoo no women at the Golden
Globes sorry anyway I've been watching a
bunch of sports a lot of hockey so
singing you know the [ __ ] what do you
call it dude how many times can updates
be available on your [ __ ] you know
your computer updates are available you
know there's some [ __ ] poor bastard
or I'm gonna Majan a group of them both
men and women just [ __ ] sitting there
updating [ __ ] working on new [ __ ]
Microsoft Word the letters have to be
clearer you know whether you know Joe's
just [ __ ] tap out it's good it's good
you just treat your [ __ ] laptop like
one of those cars in Cuba well they just
keep [ __ ] fixing them from the 1950s
you notice that [ __ ] this still driving
cars down there for the 1950s they just
keep fixing up you [ __ ] idiots out
there with you - three-year lease I like
a Duke I like a new [ __ ] I like a new
car I like my old car to get pushed it
in the [ __ ] ocean and I got into
[ __ ] the one hey they called me Mikey
new car did you just get a car and
[ __ ] drive it into the ground
nope you always got to get new [ __ ] hey
I got a flat-screen TV look at how
[ __ ] I can see his [ __ ] ballbag
hair from that procced ago damn living
room and [ __ ] 3 years later it's
considered a piece of [ __ ] then you got
a Pheo you can't even give it away you
want 50 bucks for the single doctor but
it's not compatible with my [ __ ]
laptop because I kept clicking on the
updates telling you man it's all ok man
you got to step out
man I'm seeing things actually have
seeing things say things a little
clearer even though my nose is not
[ __ ] Claire swear to God
III you know what I did you know what I
did you know I got a [ __ ] cold do you
know how you know I got a cold by being
the perfect husband for a 12-hour period
before I [ __ ] snapped that's what
happened all right we had some things
scheduled for the day before Christmas
now they by the way anybody in the music
business you know every year you know
one of these [ __ ] little pop-tarts
you know they can feel the time running
out okay it's the time on their career
is shorter than their [ __ ] [ __ ] hair
and they realize it okay the wick is
burning down to their [ __ ] clam there
and then they need a [ __ ] hit that's
gonna be playing long after they're
still relevant right they're trying
they're all piling on Christmas you know
John Legend even as talented as that guy
is he even did one just in case right he
did the baby it's cold outside he did it
for the [ __ ] you know the hairy leg
chicks out there right your body they
all Christmas so here's the thing only a
few people are as talented as John
Legend you know so now you're trying to
fill a horse into that [ __ ] race what
are you doing what happened to the old
school music managers that that look for
day lights in other parts of the room
what was the last time somebody wrote a
[ __ ] Christmas Eve song you know I
don't know how the [ __ ] it would go
that's not my goddamn jump it's the FIR
it's the night before Christmas oh boy
oh boy
after the gifts are open tomorrow it
will be depressing
were all a [ __ ] alder isn't it nice
before it all happens to take it in
right there you go it's the [ __ ] day
before Christmas I don't know what I
will catch why doesn't somebody write a
[ __ ] song about the day after
Christmas right before New Year's and
the depression of another year going by
he's starting to set in you know Jeff
[ __ ] Trent Reznor do one of those
songs I got socks yesterday you know
just make you feel [ __ ] you know what
I got socks yesterday and I was [ __ ]
psyched that's how old I am I asked for
nothing for Christmas and that's what I
got and I've never been more happier on
Christmas I got socks and underwear and
I got this little [ __ ] fancy schmancy
thing to carry cigars when I'm gonna go
meet a bunny to go smoke a cigar that's
all I got and you know what I love it
[ __ ] loved it oh my wife also got me
a sweater she got me a sweater she goes
it's cash me I put it on I go I don't
have a t-shirt on it's gonna be itchy
itchy right she's like it's cashmere and
I put it on her it's [ __ ] itchy and
she's like no it isn't ah that's funny I
really want to convey to you women out
there Kay itchy means itchy okay no
means no itchy means it she all right
the [ __ ] sweater is itchy [ __ ]
stick me in a goddamn sweater I know
what you doing I got a wedding ring
along and that already says I'm off the
market but what if what if that [ __ ]
has bad eyesight stick him in a sweater
anyway I had a fight just had the
perfect Christmas and my daughter's old
enough to you know do the whole Santa
Claus thing now and we [ __ ] up though
like she saw one of her best gifts
outside I had it outside the door and
had her on my shoulders she merely
pointed over she's like trampoline
I don't like oh Jesus alright now what
am I gonna close with and then she saw
her big dollhouse too because I couldn't
wrap it it was [ __ ] gigantic so
everything else was kind of like
actually no she got a couple of Doc
McStuffins things that she loved or
whatever but uh she was so psyched and
just like a great age you know so that
was all fun
my wife's gorgeous I got her some stuff
you know to let her know how beautiful I
thought she was she liked it and I sat
down I [ __ ] I told her because we
have a family coming over I just said
listen I'm [ __ ] sick after that
thrash you put me through on Christmas
Eve
alright because we basically was
supposed to like we got up in the
morning and like we weren't doing [ __ ]
we were gonna go to the Christmas Mass
and then we were going to go to a
Christmas party that's what it was gonna
be and then something else happened
you know we added that right we went to
a brunch which was it was all awesome
stuff but it was just it turned the
whole [ __ ] day who just went from our
day starting in three two it's starting
at nine and didn't end till 11:00 at
night and it just it just kept [ __ ]
going
my daughter barely got a nap and then
she was crying she was all upset or
anything but she was totally cool during
the mess and everything like that so and
I told her during the day I go I'm
getting sick we're doing too many things
I'm getting sick and she just went oh
sorry you want to take a quick nap what
in the 20 minutes that we that we have
left in this [ __ ] day that are
actually mine you know when I get sick I
get sick does she say sorry oh god I
wish I could come down here I love my
wife to death I'd love to break her
balls about this because she'd somehow
turn it around on me as much as she did
it the nitrous that would annoy me I
would just be fascinated with the
process so anyway I got very
little for Christmas in an awesome way
you wait when you get older you all
understand how great it is to put on a
new pair of socks on makes you feel
[ __ ] five years younger you know and
I have all these old clothes and this is
this [ __ ] Skid Row strip I'm gonna go
down there just give all that [ __ ] away
because I know if I give it to Goodwill
I got a better chance of that getting to
a [ __ ] homeless person like you think
it's gonna be a homeless person it isn't
it's just gonna be something [ __ ]
hipster picking through your [ __ ] you
know and then the rest of it I don't
know what the [ __ ] they do what they
just [ __ ] throw it out it all ends up
in the ocean as far as I can tell so I
want to thank the duck the NBA the
players when that great of them to play
hoop yesterday give you something to do
other than sit there and [ __ ] stare
at the Christmas tree with no presents
underneath it I'm out one of these
[ __ ] cold ones supposed to be working
the other supposed to be [ __ ] getting
better and they switch off they're not
supposed to both be asleep at the wheel
anywhere so both you nostrils a [ __ ]
clogged up and then you go to swallow
and there's nowhere for the [ __ ] air
to go makes you make that weird noise
anyway Celtics beat the Raptors for the
first time since 2015 in Toronto what a
statement on how tough the Raptors were
to beat it at home cuz we've had some
great teams over the last four years the
Bruins beat the Capitals why why did
they put four on him in the first period
you know why cuz I wasn't watching
that's why if I watch they have a bad
[ __ ] game you watch I'm watching the
next one we'll see actually I'm not
turning myself into the jinx alright
don't do that to me
okay is that one of us sit here and take
that I will not anyway with a [ __ ] am i
right now why does this thing keep
shutting down on me you know I'll tell
you right now how many people do you
know podcasting are so desperate to keep
their name in the game of show business
that they actually podcast with the cold
the day after Christmas by themselves
clogged-up nostrils in an old tracksuit
and fuzzy slippers all right so the new
years come and you guys get any
resolutions huh
I got a resolution we start taking
[ __ ] vitamins I'm coming on my whole
[ __ ] year I didn't drink it all this
year oh boy isn't that exciting I don't
have any awesome stories and funny
anecdotes no I'm gonna uh I you know I
got a [ __ ] I got a bunch of [ __ ] I
have to get rid of and I have to get rid
of it in a way that I know it's not
gonna end up in the ocean so what I like
to do like I have this stupid little
[ __ ] I think they call it a caddy and
it's a dumb thing that I put all these
business cards in of all these [ __ ]
people I I don't even know who they are
anymore they don't know who I am it's
just stupid right they're business cards
when in business cards end six years ago
nobody has a [ __ ] business card
anyway I get a bunch of that [ __ ] just
sitting in this little plastic hunk of
[ __ ] that I bought at Staples you know
what I do I then go down to Staples with
that thing that I bought at Staples all
right I bend down to act like I'm tying
my shoe in case they're filming me I'm
kidding I don't take it that far
I just set it down in the parking lot
near there and then some [ __ ]
scavengers gonna come in there and
they're gonna be like oh my god is that
ik free caddy and they take the [ __ ] I
do that with like you know drum [ __ ]
that I don't want I go down to Guitar
Center and I just put it in a bag and I
just leave it there and some kid comes
by and takes it sometimes people give me
drum sticks to the wrong [ __ ] sighs
what am I gonna do just throw it out
some tree died I'll bring it down there
some young [ __ ] the next goddamn
Tommy Lee or [ __ ] Tommy Aldridge all
the Tommy's from my generation right the
next John theme right they come by and
they use them that's how I throw out
[ __ ] right Oh bottle of booze that I'm
not gonna [ __ ] drink what do I do with
it
do I throw it out they pour it down the
drain
mean so it becomes part of the recycled
drinking water I knock people off their
[ __ ] sub right now I don't I don't I
go down it's an elementary school right
down the street and I just I just you
know lean it up against the chain-link
fence right no I don't do that you know
I do was I invite people over and pour a
[ __ ] I got a heavy hand we had a
Christmas party over here I get rid of
two bottles of [ __ ] it's great though I
say why am i hanging on to these [ __ ]
things I'm not gonna lie to you I could
I got a couple bottles of Pappy Van
Winkle and I you know no all right
someday I want to go to the doctor he's
just like I got good news I got bad news
all right what's the good news you're
gonna be drinking a lot of Pappy after
this next sentence anyways and I'll tell
you another thing I am all eggnog out oh
my god
Jesus Christ I think I drank a 3/4 of a
gallon of [ __ ] eggnog over the
holiday and I feel like it oh my god I
feel like [ __ ] but how about those
[ __ ] Clippers that Clippers Lakers
game was great I know snoop didn't like
it but I enjoyed it granted I'm a
Celtics fan he's a Laker fan but I
[ __ ] liked it um I thought it was a
great game and it doesn't mean anything
it's Vinny it's December like that guy
then what was his with Billings Barbara
Billingsley that [ __ ] guy who [ __ ]
blocked out LeBron shot you see him
running off the code that number one
figure the best team on Christmas Day
you don't get a ring for that that's why
I love that Leonard guy I love that guy
but she can't have a bunch of Leonard
said it'd be all super boring the whole
[ __ ] regular season
you scored 50 points what can you say
about that well you know it just gave
number 70 so I mean you don't want
anything you know you know I just don't
go to uh yeah I mean is my name
I didn't pick it my parents gave it to
be a you know government uses it to
follow me around it mean that's just how
it is I guess you know maybe some
lobbyists could maybe change those laws
but I mean I'd be honestly that I don't
hear the crowd obvious this interview
would end sooner rather than later I
think that that would be my leg saying
okay that's it all right gonna go have a
threesome what they look of uh like I'm
waiting for a bus what do you think I
don't know I'm very Christmas all right
should I do the reads here is that what
I should do just a lonely man in a
tracksuit with a cold you know even when
they redo a tunnel tape they're smart
enough to keep one side open sure the
traffic's a little bad I don't
understand what's going on here it's
like they're redoing the Lincoln Tunnel
they did but both [ __ ] sides I'm just
a little frustrated that's all hey you
know I didn't forgot to bring up how
about Eddie Murphy on SNL how great was
that okay and how great was it to be in
the beginning when he did the monologue
came out he was hilarious and then uh
all the guys that he influenced all came
out all of amazing careers Chris Rock
Dave Chappelle Tracy Morgan I was [ __ ]
I thought that was amazing I didn't
watch him bring back some of those older
characters it was surreal like what's
this guy up to now mr. Robinson his
Gumby still pissed off it was [ __ ]
great I thought I thought when he but he
got to the desk by the time he got to
the desk he was just like he never left
SNL and he was improvident and he was
making everybody laugh it was just
amazing I like what he called Colin Jost
headshot I mean that's literally like
basically a headshot is the best you're
ever gonna look it always looks like
like you're like what if say you're a
six in your headshot you look like an
eight that's just how it works
your hair is perfect your teeth a
[ __ ] white you don't have any bows
weight on you Colin Jost looks like that
walking around that's how I understood
the
to be I thought it was fellas my
favorite thing that he said and I also
liked what he had when he was on the the
bake the cake sketch I like that
although she would tithi yes yes those
are anyway that was [ __ ] awesome and
I'm hoping that that that is a little
little precursor to him doing another
stand-up special because I keep hearing
it's gonna happen and then I hear it's
just a rumor I don't know I don't know I
don't know if it's confirmed I have no
idea but uh I told you guys I know it
charges a million times but if you're
new to my podcast I saw Eddie Murphy
live doing stand-up I saw him on the raw
tour in the purple suit at great woods
and the weather girls opened up it I saw
a lot of legends of that time I saw Dice
Clay I saw him at the in 89 at the
Worcester Centrum November of 89 or
November of 88 I think was 89 I forget I
was [ __ ] amazing
I saw who's that guy he died Morton
Downey jr. I went to a live taping into
that show he took it on the road he just
had these [ __ ] these plants in the
crowd to say crazy [ __ ] he would be
screaming and yelling and until I you go
[ __ ] yourself you might have [ __ ]
good and we were just going nuts just it
just laughed with me my buddy went to
laugh at the people that were there we
kind of went there like hipsters like we
went there to laugh at it and also we
enjoyed the [ __ ] out of it I don't know
I saw a lot of 80s cool eighties [ __ ]
there was a legendary radio station in W
in Massachusetts WBC N and I 19 like 85
or 86 I went down and saw a charity
softball game where the the disc jockeys
and all the people that worked at WBC n
played a softball game against Huey
Lewis and the news in their roadies and
everybody was rootin for Huey Lewis in
the news and me and my buddy were like
heckling up
my buddy's going Huey you're gonna lose
you got nothing he was pitching I just
remembered the bass player who always
had the cool vibe and Huey Lewis with
the long trench coat and the dangling
cigarette he went up to plate still
dressed like that you know he had the
cigarette dangling and the whole day he
was [ __ ] cool as [ __ ] trying to think
what else I saw back then all that
random [ __ ] eighties [ __ ] it was such
a fun [ __ ] decade alright let's do
let's do a little bit advertising here
shall we
shall we um alright oh look what we got
here buddy helix helix there's nobody on
the planet like you okay there's nobody
on the planet like you so why would you
buy a generic mattress built for
everyone else
next please mention all the talking
points below why is that in the copy
I've never understood that if you
[ __ ] write it I'm gonna read helix
sleep built a sleep quiz that takes two
minutes to complete sorry
[ __ ] congested here and they use the
answer to match your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress
whether you're a side a hot like a plush
or a firm bed whether you're a top or a
bottom with HELOCs there's no more
guessing or compromising just go to
helix sleep calm slash bird take their
two minutes sleep quiz and they'll match
you to a mattress that will give you the
best sleep of your life for couples
hellix can even split the mattress down
the middle providing individual support
needs and feel preference and feel
preferences for each side well then when
you haven't sex which side of you want
I guess depends on which position you're
in missionary style you got a bang her
on her side of the bed she's riding you
I we gotta get on my side I need no
support for my lower back oh oh but it
hurts my knees alright
why the [ __ ] is it always her way he
starts to lose his dick do i not turn
you want anymore no it's it's the lack
of firmness over the side of the bed my
Dick's doing what my back is doing right
now it's collapsing into the mattress
alright this is not part of the copy
helix sleep was even awarded the number
one best overall mattress pic of 2019 by
GQ & Wired magazine I don't know people
don't blow Maine magazines and CNN
called it the most comfortable mattress
they've ever slept on how many issues a
month does Wired oh sorry I'm thinking
about the 80s he's a coke jokes people
they have a 10-year warranty and you get
to try it out for hundreds a nice
risk-free right now helix is offering
120 for up to 125 dollars off mattresses
mattress orders for our listeners get up
to 125 dollars off helix sleep comm
slash birth
that's helix sleep calm slash bur for
100 up to 125 dollars off your mattress
order helix sleep calm slash burr Jesus
Christ what is it about sitting down
that just reminds you that you have this
[ __ ] cold
right now I got it I gotta sign this
[ __ ] thing are you coming in yes I am
I would yet okay yes I am it's for work
alright then I mean it probably podcast
give you behind the scenes of what
they're texting right there in that
moment I don't have anything to hide all
right well what are we gonna do with the
final 8 6 6 minutes of this podcast
let's talk about some of the goals that
you want to achieve huh all right let's
start with the basics who are you with
are you happy with who you are with do
they charge oh if you don't like them
get rid of them tell them to be
eat it that's what you do you know
breaking up with somebody is really hard
but you know if you buy the Thriller
album that's me can you imagine if you
actually have the balls to do that break
up with somebody with beat it going on
in the background boo doo doo doo it's
not working out baby doodoo doo baby
beep-beep I [ __ ] hate the [ __ ]
sound of your voice no you can't do that
you gotta be nice about it it's not you
it's me don't say that no it's it's you
and how me interacts with you it's not
working out I'm not happy I'm looking
for more than this there's got to be a
bigger love out there than this right or
if you're in love [ __ ] lock it down
oh my god I was at a [ __ ] party the
other night
somebody has to do shiest [ __ ]
question you can possibly ask of a
couple you know what it is
how long have you guys been together is
so beyond [ __ ] rude you should be
able to take a drink and just throw it
in the person's face you just you're
just trying to cause a [ __ ] fight
with that couple how long have you guys
been together you know no matter what
the number is it's always why people
always do that [ __ ] then what happens
then you get engaged oh wow yeah you
gonna try to have a kid right away all
right then you have a kid you gotta all
right every [ __ ] ah they're the
[ __ ] I [ __ ] hate people it's not
even that they ask that it's that they
do that and they act like they don't
know what the [ __ ] they're doing son
wait wait have you guys been together
for four for two or two and a half years
two and a half Wow that's all that needs
to be said if you don't like somebody
that's a great thing to say in front of
this significant other oh my god I can't
[ __ ] breathe Jesus Christ I don't
take any of that [ __ ] it all last night
I did I actually took some nyquil and
then I watched uncut gems for the second
time [ __ ] incredible movie you got to
go see it and then I went to sleep and I
woke up with what you're hearing right
now and I went and I took another shot
of it and in my head I was like oh my
god I'm just like little wait I'm like
one of those Atlanta rappers it's like I
want to be drinking lean
but I don't know what the other
ingredients are because I believe nyquil
and sprite with a cough drop is lean
well drank what do the hell it's called
they got dayquil right can you can you
[ __ ] do some jello shots of dayquil
and actually legally get behind the
wheel of a car these are the questions
that I ask anyway this is what I'm gonna
do okay
I'm Nev I will I would net I've never
[ __ ] asked anybody that how long you
guys been individually to the guy I
would never say that to the woman you
hate the boyfriend oh yeah how long you
been together you know the only way I
would ask that would be if I was trying
to bang her and it's just like I she's
locked down all right well how long you
been with this guy yeah so well you look
at a holding pattern eight would you
like to [ __ ] and refuel oh we're sorry
anyway so I'm gonna clean up my [ __ ] and
I'm gonna write a Christmas Eve song the
day is wide
open nobody writes a Black Friday song
that that day is still [ __ ] open
nobody's really writing a good
Thanksgiving so look at speaking of
uncut Chibs look at Adam Sandler nobody
wrote a [ __ ] Chanukah suck it forever
and then he wrote one he had that every
[ __ ] year you gotta jump on this [ __ ]
that nobody's doing I think it's high
time that somebody wrote a Christmas Eve
song okay bill we got it anyway no I'm
gonna get a couple things might like
there's one thing about my house is I
don't want [ __ ] clutter okay and it's
it's you know it's it's a very difficult
thing to do with when you when you with
a woman I'm nesting
no you're just buying [ __ ] and you're
not dealing with your [ __ ] emotions
that's what you're doing
oh Jesus bill jeez I thought you enjoyed
your Christmas gifts sorry I'm not even
this upset with anything in the world
right now it's just I can't [ __ ]
breathe
so everything's gonna sound a little
[ __ ] little upsetting this week you
know be great if I actually had to do a
read about [ __ ] helping our kids in
the [ __ ] mood of it
you know each day these little [ __ ]
bastards don't have enough to [ __ ] it
ain't and be nice if you could break off
a little bit of your sandwich you're
trying you know [ __ ] you know dry
freeze it whatever you gotta do get it
to them so it's not stale maybe then
what do they give a [ __ ] they don't have
any food they'll still [ __ ] eat it
anyway oh god I got a [ __ ] headache
too but I gotta go do all this [ __ ]
no I uh
two things all right the garage is a
place I play drums in and it's a place
where I [ __ ] work out and I keep my
truck that's it
it is not a place to stick the [ __ ] that
doesn't fit in the [ __ ] house anymore
cuz you bought more [ __ ] if something
needs if my wife is starting to put
something the garage I'm like we're
selling that we're giving that away
it's a but I like it then why isn't it
in the house you know you like me do you
make me live in the garage you're
setting this thing to the Guerette
you're done with it it's over let it go
okay but I like date they always go with
the emotion you know we got a couple
another [ __ ] thing I can't [ __ ]
stand I hate when you do laundry right
and then the clothes just sit there on
top but like there's always just clothes
in there
it's like if they [ __ ] dirty wash
them if they clean fold them and [ __ ]
put them away instead of having this
[ __ ] I fight drives me up the [ __ ]
wall say what we got to get rid of you
know those stupid [ __ ] bags you have
so you don't go in you know use plastic
bags we have about a thousand of those
[ __ ] things we have more than what
I'm gonna [ __ ] there's nothing I'm
gonna go down to [ __ ] Skid Row give it
to those people those people love bags
they don't love the reason that they
need bags but they'd love to have a bad
[ __ ] going down there you know there
was grabbing plastic bags look it's
they're recycling them in a way I don't
know I just might think I got a
flat-screen TV I don't like you don't
I'm gonna take that off the wall take it
right down to [ __ ] Skid Row right
those people can all sit around and
[ __ ] watch bowl games and then watch
themselves get interviewed about being
homeless on their own TV with some chick
who's impossibly hot but evidently can't
act so she became a on location reporter
newscasters the ladies they used to be
journalists now they're just these
[ __ ] hotties have you notice that
they just [ __ ] smoke shows I think
that's why you know nobody's doing
anything about global warning warming
warning global warming because the
[ __ ] reporters they're so goddamn
good-looking you just like Jesus Christ
look at that guy's teeth how are they
that white oh my god look at the [ __ ]
rat on that broad the polar bears are
dying yeah they're your [ __ ] teeth
are whiter than a polar bear sweetheart
you know but you can't get ugly people
to read the news because then everybody
you're distracted by that what you need
is somebody in the middle we got to get
fives and sixes to read the [ __ ]
loose the important [ __ ]
and it needs to be unbiased which is
impossible I forget it I thought I had a
[ __ ] solution there it's not gonna
[ __ ] work
fives and sixes just walking around
resenting the [ __ ] you know the Jan
Brady so [ __ ] looks jealous of ugly
people and good-looking people ugly
people are drumlin for me well at least
you get a reaction you know you don't
regular people aren't they like the
[ __ ] you know the you know when you
order something you know those peanuts
they're like cushions whatever the [ __ ]
you bought good the good-looking person
is the product that's in the box and
then ugly people are the Box especially
especially if it got delivered by UPS
the way they [ __ ] overworked those
people the way they kick them around
Amazon overwork they're people too but
they're too [ __ ] sleepy to [ __ ]
kick a box around alright I think that's
the podcast right yeah batteries love
Jesus Christ
alright I apologize this this one came
off a little you know not us you know
you wouldn't know I have I actually said
to my wife last night that this is the
best Christmas I've ever had I just
[ __ ] I loved it I got to read the
night before Christmas to my daughter
and she's been helping me with my anger
you know big time she just goes daddy no
yelling daddy beat daddy you have to be
nice to people like you're right you're
right buddy you're right sorry about
that
and then she always smile so we do like
she does the thumbs up but you got to
touch the thumbs that's what we do so
now she so knows when I'm losing my
temper that even when I get like whisper
I'll be driving down the street and I'll
just become like this [ __ ]
[ __ ] but you had daddy no
screaming like all right buddy you're
right you're right
thumbs up bow it's amazing it's actually
it's actually working so anyway all
right thank you to everybody listen to
my podcast this year thank you the NBA
players for working on Christmas and
entertaining everybody that's it I hope
all you guys have a happy healthy and
successful 2020 I hope you [ __ ]
follow your hearts go after what you
want
say what you're feeling you know but
don't be a [ __ ] [ __ ] and I hope
you have an open mind and if somebody
has a difference of opinion than you do
there's no reason to cancel them you can
just move on we can all be adults right
let's try to get along a little more in
2020 there's nothing wrong with this
state there's nothing wrong with that
state no states are any colors it's just
people doing what they're doing in their
[ __ ] state everybody [ __ ] relax
all right you know and if you're an
adult you should be above wanting to win
an award all right that's it everybody
go [ __ ] yourselves I'll see you Monday
morning from Monday December 26 2011
ladies and gentlemen it is the final
Monday of this year huh what are you
gonna do with it you're gonna sit around
and look at those gifts that you kind of
wanted but not really cuz some Contin
buy you the right thing despite the fact
you [ __ ] wrote it down yeah no
turtlenecks I don't want any [ __ ]
turtlenecks I know but I just thought
you might like this one what made you
think that sweetheart
I'm not yelling
this is frustration oh you [ __ ] yell
- what the [ __ ] is with people they sit
there and they [ __ ] right and they go
oh my god you're so hard to shop for I
just don't know what to get you just
make me see make them a [ __ ]
Leisha give him four goddamn things and
what happens on Christmas you don't get
one of those [ __ ] things right and
you're sitting there going ah I don't
want to be a selfish [ __ ] but what the
[ __ ] you know you told me you wanted the
little Kitty carry-all [ __ ] goddamn
iPad thing didn't I go out and get you
that [ __ ] it's unreal
you know it's just every [ __ ] year
there's this [ __ ] or they or they
they get you the wrong [ __ ] color I'm
telling you it's the most frustrating
[ __ ] thing ever so now what happens
it's it's after Christmas and now you
got to go return all this [ __ ]
I'll just go online and buy yourself
whatever the [ __ ] you wanted anyways
right isn't that what you got to do I
don't know right now this is you know I
know Christmas is you know totally an
American holiday here so I don't mean to
close out or shout out any of my [ __ ]
listeners over there in Europe I know
you don't celebrate Thanksgiving a
Christmas I get it
it's part of our history Santa Claus is
American I just love doing [ __ ] like
that cuz I know a good 15 percent of my
European listeners actually thought I
was serious that I didn't think that
they had Christmas do they know I know
you guys celebrate Christmas you know
why cuz the Vatican is over there in
Italy bellissimo huh those el dente
douchebags with their big [ __ ] hats
walking around trying to tell you how to
live life as they steal gold from Jewish
people in the [ __ ] world war ii as
they play a little patty cake with some
eight-year-olds nuts
right the [ __ ] is wrong with how long
can you sit there I look I get the seven
deadly sins I get two Ten Commandments
just live your life that way all right
but for the love of God you know you
know kills me about people really get
into this [ __ ] you know and I guess I
should respect them cuz you know for all
I know this stuff's 100 percent true but
my gut tells me it isn't my gut tells me
that's a bunch of made-up [ __ ]
stories by a bunch of goddamn psychopath
that's what my gut tells me
you know and I've been watching a lot of
Oprah lately okay and I'll tell you
something about that big fish I'd
[ __ ] jackass she says to go with you
gut all right
and like the Catholic Church she's also
worth a billion dollars okay so I'm
going with her [ __ ] wide flat ass
sitting on that big [ __ ] sofa telling
me how to live my [ __ ] life all right
Oprah you broke through you broke the
seal I'm listening to you now go with
your gut well that's what my gut tells
me you know I remember when I was a kid
when I was just a lad when I was just
two tyke when I was somebody who didn't
have a license and I rode around on a
bicycle cuz no one was scared of
pedophiles back in the day cuz there
weren't any they were just called dirty
old men stay away from he's a dirty old
man you know and they always had on
Dickies and then you know and their dick
was hanging down to their [ __ ]
goddamn knees right stayed away from
them we didn't have video games so we
were in good cardio shape back then you
could run away from a [ __ ] dirty old
man but anyways when I was just a lad
and I was just a child lace listened to
all those heavy metal albums and that
was the big thing in the 80s oh my god
these albums are making people do [ __ ]
that is evil it's making them kill
themselves it's making them kill others
it's causing them to do drugs it's
causing all this [ __ ] [ __ ] so what
would they do they try to take Ozzy
Osbourne with that suicide solution they
try to take that out of the stores
remember rob halford
huh that gay screaming queen that none
of us knew was gay despite the fact he
did everything in his [ __ ] he could
possibly do to let us know that he was
blowing people at the end of the concert
we didn't know we had no idea they came
down on him they tried to get rid of
Judas Priest records all that [ __ ] all
of that [ __ ] you know what kills me I
was thinking of this the other day that
if the Bible was a heavy metal album I
mean [ __ ] kidding me if any heavy
metal album caused the amount of deaths
that the Bible did cause the amount of
people to go [ __ ] crazy
you know that the Bible Didier let's
[ __ ] what I got yanked right out of
record town right out of strawberries
records and tapes right out of Good
Vibrations
remember all those record stores you
know they would be over but the thing
about it is is it's making too much
money you know it's like the Michael
Jackson Thriller of albums it's just
it's a [ __ ] moneymaker it keeps
people in line there's a lot of good
stuff about the Bible I mean I really
think that if they didn't have some sort
of religious moral code in the world
people would just be walking around
shaking that dixit everybody wouldn't
they I mean think about that if there
was no fear of going to hell how many
murders would you have under your belt
at this point or at least psychotic
[ __ ] beatdowns wouldn't you have a
bunch you know Oh better yet when you
hit wouldn't you got your [ __ ] ass
kicked I mean what he gotten killed for
some of your [ __ ] behavior every once
in a while you see a glimpse of what the
world would be like if we just [ __ ]
threw down which brings me to our one
and only YouTube video of the week did
you guys see the the beatdown in
McDonald's where that dude was standing
there and these two came into the
McDonald's it's the one right down there
on I get off the West 4th Street e train
right there down in the village you know
two blocks over Joe's pizza that's a
good slice of pizza all right right as
you come out of there Spike Lee's
probably filming people playing
basketball and handball go well y'all
get your New York shitty right I trashed
him on Twitter yesterday he was talking
[ __ ] about my Boston Celtics you know so
I I said something but I kept it funny
hoping that he would still put me in one
of his movies you know and I could
either play a complete nerdy white guy
who doesn't understand black people or
an over-the-top racist
[Laughter]
um anyways I give a [ __ ] get me in a
movie I'll do it so anyways that
McDonald's down there so these two
ladies they walk into the McDonald's
okay and they try and buy a goddamn Big
Mac and a happy meal and they think they
throw a $50 bill on the counter right
there major red flag
who the [ __ ] pays for McDonald's with a
$50 bill who even has $50 and is gonna
go into McDonald's nobody there's not
been a $50 bill in McDonald's since they
started that [ __ ] place so these
ladies try to pass this 15 the guy
behind the counter he starts looking at
the 50 and he's like excuse me ladies I
don't think that this is real so they go
listen [ __ ] you better give us a
goddamn fish filet and whatever quarter
pounder with cheese and give us our
[ __ ] change or we're gonna [ __ ] you up
and he said I don't think so and then
this girl just hauls off and slaps the
guy slaps him and then the other one and
then she climbs up over the counter now
the other one just starts just really
slowly just walking around the counter
like well I guess we gotta [ __ ] this guy
up this is what we do and the guy backs
up into the frialator area and I don't
know where the [ __ ] he found this
goddamn lead pipe it was like a cart you
know like in the cartoons when Bugs
Bunny would just sort of you know he'd
be standing sideways she'd SEVIS side
view and he'd have a problem and he
would just turned it to the blind side
and all of a sudden he'd have a giant
hammer and he'd hit Elmer Fudd over the
head you'd be like where the [ __ ] did
that come from
was that leaning up against his right
rabbit leg and I didn't see it
how did Elmer Fudd not [ __ ] see it
now with that gigantic head of his how
did he not view that as a threat this
guy did the real-life version of that he
was backing up backing up and he was
next to some french fries and next thing
you know he's got this lead pipe oh and
he just [ __ ] starts wearing these
girls out with it bam bam bam
I got to give it up to those girls they
took a good
for each and then they disappeared under
the counter and he just keeps [ __ ]
hitting them Bam Bam Bam and this lady's
going and he just keeps [ __ ] going
like a [ __ ] like this [ __ ]
screaming it's like those little doggy
toys you know his little doggy toys that
squeak that you know they make those
little noises you know why dogs get so
excited cuz it sounds like a [ __ ]
animal dying and it taps into their wild
animal side so this [ __ ] is thinking
she's helping [ __ ] she should have been
like excuse me is that something you
really want to do instead she's going
and this guy's he just [ __ ] he won't
stop hitting him will not stop [ __ ]
hitting them all right so you know this
[ __ ] works
[ __ ] too lady's attack a guy doesn't
make a difference they can sit there and
slap you around like you're a [ __ ]
cartoon you're supposed to be like armed
they're women I need to respect them
this guy said [ __ ] that [ __ ] that and
like Bugs Bunny I turn to the side and
there was this magic lead-pipe and he
[ __ ] kicked the [ __ ] out of both of
them so of course he gets arrested for
assault and I got am it I was totally
supporting what he was doing through the
first 37 hits it's the last nineteen
that I'm just like alright alright okay
okay Neal was saying he actually was
like that dude and drive when he stomped
that kids that guy's headed in the
elevator he kind of went to that level
but at the end of the day I'm like well
that's why you don't go around slapping
people in the [ __ ] face because they
might have gone to magician school and
they know how to magically have a
[ __ ] goddamn lead pipe out of nowhere
alright so this guy's going to trial and
I'm thinking there's no [ __ ] way then
you find out this dude actually has a
record this guy went to jail for
manslaughter all right and he got out
and there's only two places that you can
get a job after you've gone to jail for
manslaughter
you can either get into show business or
you can work at McDonald's
all right you can't get a job at [ __ ]
Macy's that there is a glass ceiling
when you go to jail for [ __ ]
manslaughter that's it unless your dad
owns a company you can get into sales
you can sell somebody a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] car but you're not selling a
Mercedes you're gonna be at uh Sam's hot
car lot down the street right reservoir
dogs anybody that's why right there okay
before I even continue talking about
this story that right there
ladies and gentlemen is why you don't
walk around slapping perfect strangers
in the face it's because you don't know
their backstory you don't know what
they've done you don't know what they're
capable of doing this is a guy who
already took somebody's life and you're
looking at him like oh hey what's up
there Mick French fry guy take this 50
or I'm gonna slap the [ __ ] out of you
and you don't realize that this guy has
been in [ __ ] prison all right he
probably knows how to turn that piece of
paper with ulysses s grant turned that
into a [ __ ] shank somehow he figured
out how to [ __ ] do it
you know what I mean so these two get an
unbelievable life lesson and why you
can't walk around acting like you're
some action hero in real life so anyway
so it goes to trial and I can't [ __ ]
believe it I'm like there's no way this
guy's not getting convicted he's [ __ ]
he's a guy he beat down two women with a
[ __ ] pipe he went above and beyond
with this [ __ ] and he's he has a record
it's [ __ ] over right it's over he's
not rich you know it's over this guy is
going to jail I can't [ __ ] believe it
he got off the guy got acquitted so for
once on the podcast I'm actually happy
and I can tell you
if they convicted him of a lesser charge
because he just kept hitting him I
wouldn't have been mad cuz I would have
been like dude they were down they were
[ __ ] down and they were down and then
they were part of the tile and you was
still [ __ ] hitting him
we have this clip by the way on the mmm
podcast page has now been turned over
the new fan page it's just billboard
calm you just go to my podcast page and
anyways we'll have the video up there
and all that [ __ ] so anyway he got off
and they charged the women with [ __ ] and
I don't think that they're getting off
they'll probably get lesser because
they're because they're women you know
what I mean and that's just women always
get less time it seems you know because
at the end of the day the judge thinks
well maybe if I give him a little less
time they'll come over here and blow me
under my robe I don't know what the deal
is I told you that story a few weeks ago
when I saw that this amazing trumpet
player you know I was like man never
heard of this guy and I found out he was
murdered by his [ __ ] girlfriend in
1972 and she got out of jail in 1978 I
would go to jail longer for parking
tickets than she did for killing a guy
shot him right up on the bandstand took
out a gun and [ __ ] shot to stay at an
argument she left she came back with the
gun and she shot this dude on the
[ __ ] Bandstand all these goddamn
witnesses and she did that in 72 and was
out by 78 so let's just say they they
they went they flew through her trial
sent her right to trial she still only
did five and a half years I don't know I
don't know how that [ __ ] works and I
bet she was able to forgive herself the
[ __ ] sociopath that she is and she
was able to go on and live her life and
then that guy is in the ground cold as
his goddamn trumpet so anyways what does
this all mean people what does it all
mean this is what it means it's the day
after Christmas
who's kidding who you got some of the
stuff you wanted you got a lot of [ __ ]
you didn't want and you got some other
[ __ ] that reminded you how [ __ ] old
you are all right now you're in this
sort of lull in between Christmas and
New Year's all right you're probably at
home you're visiting some relatives or
even worse your goddamn in-laws and
you're in this miserable state okay and
you got this weird feeling of like I
just want to go home all right but when
I go home I have to go back to work and
the [ __ ] starts over again is there
no end is no [ __ ] oasis that I can
look to well ladies and gentlemen I have
a suggestion why don't you buy yourself
something nice huh and better yet why
don't you go on amazon.com
holy [ __ ] is this a commercial I think
it is I finally figured out how I'm
gonna try and make some money on this
podcast this is what you do people all
right who's kidding who you know we all
thought about the people who had less
than us we all did that yesterday all
right but that was yesterday and now
it's today it's time to go back to being
the selfish [ __ ] that you are that I am
that that guy sitting across from you on
the subway right now is you [ __ ]
listening to this podcast is all right
go out and get yourself something nice
all right if you want to [ __ ] help me
out in the podcast just go to Bill burr
comm you click on podcast and if you
look on the right-hand side of the page
right under where it says to click on
iTunes to subscribe you'll see
amazon.com shop Earth's biggest
selection if you click on there and you
go to Amazon and you buy something
they're gonna kick me some of that cash
ain't gonna cost you a [ __ ] dime
extra not gonna cost you an extra dime
all right and you'll actually kick some
money to me for doing this podcast every
[ __ ] week and then you know what I'm
gonna do 10% of everything that I make
I'm kicking over to the Wounded Warriors
Project okay so what are you killing
three birds with one stone
all right you make it up for the fact
that you got that awful [ __ ]
turtleneck that you didn't want all
right now you're going out and getting
yourself an iPad or some [ __ ] that you
really
see you're satisfying that meanwhile
you're kicking me a little bit of money
for making you giggle every goddamn
Monday and then on top of that you're
helping out the soldiers who came back
who got wounded that right there is
what's known as hitting a [ __ ]
trifecta ladies and gentlemen I can't do
any better than that and the great thing
is is you don't even have to [ __ ] do
it it's totally up to you
all right you [ __ ] can I make it any
more easier than that so please if you
gotta buy anything on the internet
please do it on amazon.com and go
through my website on the podcast page
and just click right on that box I'd
really appreciate it
you know cuz like I'd like to buy myself
some stuff you know eventually I'm gonna
get a chair down here you know I'm
laying on the floor right now with my
head leaned up against a guitar case of
a guitar I can't even [ __ ] play one
of these days I'm gonna get the balls to
start playing my guitar on this podcast
so you guys can hear how truly [ __ ]
awful I am despite the fact that I've
been playing for you so anyways what are
we gonna talk about this week on the
podcast we are 20 minutes in 20
tremendous minutes and this has been a
good podcast so far it's been a lot of
passion it's been a lot of screaming
anyways oh I know what I wanted to talk
about how about a moment of silence for
another two for the next two great men
who are about ready to be sliced in half
by their [ __ ] ex-wives how about a
moment of silent for Kobe Bryant
that [ __ ] warrior okay who had an
injury to his [ __ ] right hand that
would have kept most people out for half
a season he didn't even miss a [ __ ]
game showed up hitting all kinds of big
shots that absolute [ __ ] warrior he
is about ready to have to fork over a
hundred and ninety million dollars to
his [ __ ] ex-wife and I might tell
other than I want to talk to all the
[ __ ] women right now
we're going that's right that's right
you know this is what I want from you
guys this week all right I want you to
justify the [ __ ] divorce laws in this
country I want you to justify them I
want you to tell me why she deserves a
hundred ninety million dollars I want
you to justify it don't just go WOW that
that's because that's the law there you
go I don't want that I want you to
justify it like if I asked you why is
murder illegal you wouldn't be like wow
that's the law you'd be like because
life is the most precious thing on this
planet and everything has the right to
be alive and you need to respect that
you only get one life and for someone to
take your life is the worst thing you
could thats how you would defend that
law I have [ __ ] racked my brain to
try and justify how anybody is entitled
to a hundred and ninety million dollars
of somebody else's [ __ ] money
remember that story I told you last week
sure we all do I'm gonna bring it up
this [ __ ] guy got accused of rape
gets convicted goes to jail 25 years in
[ __ ] prison they find out afterwards
through dead the new DNA technology that
he didn't [ __ ] do it without a doubt
we had the wrong guy
you know what he got for 25 years of
trying to make sure somebody didn't
stick their ding-a-ling and his [ __ ]
doorknob then he makes sense whatever he
got four million dollars four million
bucks this [ __ ] has been living high on
the [ __ ] hog for 10 [ __ ] years you
know can't even hit a [ __ ] lay up on
a goddamn nerf who said and she's gonna
get a hundred ninety million [ __ ]
dollars
ladies I want you to justify tieu [ __ ]
justified that to me
that is the biggest crock of [ __ ]
[ __ ] ever you know what I you know what
I love and well he [ __ ] around he
[ __ ] her out yeah he did [ __ ] around
so he should have to pay for it but
shouldn't be a hundred ninety million
dollars come on that's [ __ ]
ridiculous
some guy gets falsely accused for rape
spends twenty five years in Rikers
Island people slashing each other's
faces throwing boiling water on each
other people getting raped all this
[ __ ] [ __ ] you got to go through and
you only get four million dollars this
[ __ ] is gonna get a hundred ninety
million those I love how its looked down
upon to to cheat on your wife but it's
totally fine to tell somebody that you
love them when you really don't just
because of all the shiny [ __ ] that they
have you know look at this look at this
woman he [ __ ] around on her she busted
him for five [ __ ] years ago the
relationships over the trust is gone
that relationship was [ __ ] over why
did she stay cuz he bought her that big
yellow [ __ ] diamond really that's why
she stays and then what does she do she
wanted out right then she wanted out
right then but that money was too
[ __ ] good and that [ __ ] stuck around
that big yellow diamonds showing it off
any [ __ ] where she could write and
then what does she do she hangs around
like some jaded cop trying to get her
[ __ ] pension she sticks around for
ten [ __ ] years the second ten years
comes around she gives herself a
Christmas gift hey Coby go [ __ ] yourself
by the way that'll cost you a hundred
ninety million dollars all right in my
world this is how that would work if
that if she wanted the entire one
hundred ninety million I'm really
burning a lot of material here cuz I'm
gonna [ __ ] vent about this on stage so
you're hearing this first this is like
when you hear one of those Zeppelin
songs before they [ __ ] polish it off
alright this is too good not to [ __ ]
say on stage I have to do this [ __ ] if I
do say so myself or maybe I just love
ranting about this [ __ ] this is this is
how she should get this [ __ ] money
alright
hey hey whatever your name is
Bryant you know it's not amazing how you
never know what their [ __ ] names are
you know cuz cuz they don't win any
[ __ ] championships and do anything
right um this is how I think that she
should get the hundred ninety million
all right you start off no matter what
mrs. whatever-your-name-is Bryant you're
getting thirty million dollars okay
which is plenty of [ __ ] money you
raise a whole goddamn family on that
live in a nice [ __ ] house and have a
nice car and still have twenty million
left over alright so no matter what
you're getting thirty million you want
to get up to 190 million and let's go
down to the Staples Center sweetheart
all right we're gonna start off easy you
give him a basketball you [ __ ] have
the whole place jam-packed with people
screaming at her shaking the signs and
blowing air horns right alright if you
hit a layup mrs. whatever-your-name-is
Bryant we're gonna give you another five
million right she hits that you moved in
the next round then you go to the foul
line you want to take another twenty
million you got to hit a foul shot and
everybody screaming just have a bunch of
[ __ ] divorced guys sleeping on futons
stand up on the backboard screaming at
this [ __ ] you hit that you move to the
half-court line you hit it you get only
get one shot - just like Kobe at the end
of the [ __ ] game how he made all this
money by hitting the big shots when
there was [ __ ] 20,000 people
screaming at him who didn't want them to
do it you go to the [ __ ] half-court
line you hit that what are we up to what
are you up to that's 50 million 55
million we'll give you 50 million 50
million if you hit a half-court then you
go to the full court you go full court
if you hit that you get you can even hit
off the backboard we don't give a [ __ ]
you'll get the other 90 that's how you
get you 190 why don't you [ __ ] earn
it it's unreal Mel Gibson's wife Mel
Gibson's wife you know has she even shot
a home movie she stands to get he's
worth at one point was worth 800 million
she's gonna get four hundred million
dollars alright I want somebody some
female some human being out there with a
vagina
to send me an email I want you to
justify justify four hundred million
dollars tell me why I don't think you
can do it other than say well that's
what the law says hat twisted hair right
it's [ __ ] ridiculous
do you know in some states if you're
riding in a car with with like a girl
who's not of age and she's in her bare
feet that's considered statutory rape
does that make any [ __ ] sense
it doesn't doesn't well I'm gonna tell
you right now these [ __ ] divorce laws
make as much sense as that they're like
these old archaic [ __ ] laws this is
the thing you know there's a lot of
disadvantages to being a lady but you
know one of the main advantages of being
a woman is that you can be an absolute
[ __ ] bum you could be a bum you can
have no [ __ ] job no Drive you cannot
achieve anything in life and still come
out the other side worth 400 million
dollars do you know what happens to a
guy if he's a bum he's a bum he's
[ __ ] homeless other than Stedman
Stedman Oprah's [ __ ] whatever the
hell he is he's the only guy I ever saw
that figured out how to be a [ __ ] bum
oh there's actually Glenn let's be fair
kevin federline
kevin federline is a bum that guy is a
bum Britney Spears even built him his
own goddamn recording studio and he
still couldn't make a hit right then
they get divorced and what does he do
sits on his ass and becomes a fat [ __ ]
you know getting Popeye's fried chicken
off of Britney Spears alimony payments
he's a bum so I guess it can't be done
but come on who's kidding who it's very
few and far between you know I don't
know maybe women are coming up maybe
they are making more money I saw all
those Christmas ads those Lexus ads
where these women were
buying their guys cars and I got to
admit I was sitting I started acting
like a woman when I saw that commercial
I was like Nia why don't you buy me a
car like this fictitious couple that we
see on television that really bothered
me
seeing that commercial where these women
were out there buying cars not because
my male ego couldn't handle some broad
buying me a car it's just the fact that
they're putting this out there was
multiple commercials as if this [ __ ] is
actually going on is if there's so many
[ __ ] women out there buying their
[ __ ] men's a car that it's worthy of
putting it out there like this is some
mainstream [ __ ] that happens hey fellas
how many guys honey I mean your male
friends got a [ __ ] goddamn Volkswagen
forget about Lexus for Christmas anybody
do you see any of your male friends
walking outside screaming like a [ __ ]
in that bathrobe jumping up and down and
looking at some shiny new car with a big
ribbon on it has that ever happened I
Brad Oprah did it I bet Britney did it
who else Sandra Bullock she married a
bum that's another guy you know those
guys ought to write a book because
they're really treading on some female
[ __ ] like how to live like a Hooters
chick as a guy you know how did just be
an absolute [ __ ] bum and still come
out the other side of goddamn
millionaire
I got me on to you I couldn't [ __ ] do
it if I was a [ __ ] bum all right let
me just let's listen let's just say I
was married to somebody some lady right
and she's just running some goddamn
Empire coming home every day dressed
like [ __ ] Nancy Reagan you know
goddamn brooch just to let you know how
powerful she is and she's buying me all
this [ __ ] after what I would have to
leave the relationship I would have to
leave and she'd be like the bill you
have nothing maybe that's the point
I got nothing I'm a [ __ ] loser
I feel like I'm I feel like I'm 14 years
old and I'm still living at home with my
parents I can't I don't have a job I
don't have any goals am I
doing anything I'm just [ __ ] sitting
here going to the gym okay I know what
everything costs on the price is right I
shouldn't know that do you understand
that I'm sick of playing tennis with the
maid I have to do something with my life
this is [ __ ] pathetic I know I
thought it was what I wanted I know I
got a [ __ ] glow I own sports bar
I thought the beers on tap I got the NFL
NBA NHL and MLB packages and I'm still
not happy because I'm a bum
mrs. Reagan all right
I'm out of here just give me time to
find a job in a one-bedroom apartment or
a [ __ ] studio I have to get out of
here
you know but these broads don't give a
[ __ ] Kobe Bryant's ex-wife is a bum and
she's gonna be worth close to 200
million dollars do you understand that
do it he probably won a game of checkers
in her life you know maybe she was good
at chutes and ladders yeah what does she
do I bet she has some [ __ ] online
business that's what those rich broads
always do so they can act like they have
some [ __ ] business but still stay at
home and their [ __ ] Jam jams I'm
working on a computer you know going to
[ __ ] US magazine.com all [ __ ] day
you're a bum mrs. whatever-your-name-is
Bryant you're a [ __ ] bum you're a bum
get a [ __ ] job the [ __ ] is it gonna
say on your tombstone suck the right
dick oh man I got all of that one uh all
right it's now I'm actually sick of
talking about it maybe I won't maybe
that won't go to stage who the [ __ ]
knows go to stage did I just say that
we're taking this to the stage we're
having a big production all right where
the [ __ ] is the Monday morning podcast
this is this is the Monday morning
podcast everybody if you're wondering
what this is this is the ramblings
a balding redheaded male in his early
soon-to-be mid 40s um all right here we
go I got some health advice you know I'm
always giving you guys advice from all
my failures
I'm here's some health advice from
Sweden hey Bill I heard that advice you
got about losing weight and I say [ __ ]
that wanna be macho douchebag alright
let's let's go back this guy last week
actually his advice was you just eat
like a [ __ ] animal for eight hours a
day whatever the [ __ ] you want I'm
paraphrasing here and then you just
don't eat [ __ ] for the rest of the day
basically like a caveman like he just
made a kill like he just took down a
bison except it's made out of Oreo
cookies I know he wasn't suggesting Oreo
cookies but he was just saying eat like
a [ __ ] animal for eight hours a day
and then you don't eat the other 16 and
evidently that works for him okay I
don't know whether that's right or wrong
but I'm gonna I'm gonna go out on a limb
and say there wasn't a lot of fat [ __ ]
homeless people but they also I mean
homeless cavemen that's funny I was
picturing cavemen and I immediately said
homeless
anyways let's plow ahead so this guy
says that that's some macho [ __ ] [ __ ]
that he said to stay in shape you don't
need to fast like a liberal hippie [ __ ]
oh god why is faster than considered
liberal nobody nobody who votes
Republican fasts I heard it's actually
good for you every once in a while to do
it to just that's like the one part of
your body that never really gets a rest
other than when you're sleeping you know
but you'll take like two three days off
or going to the gym you know what I mean
right your ears are a little tired
you'll stay away from loud noises for a
few weeks but every day is your [ __ ]
chowing down so anyways evidently
fasting that also makes you a liberal
hippie [ __ ] if you take an hour walk
every day or go running thirty minutes a
day and eat healthy with a moderate
amount of carbs high protein and a good
amount of fat and lift weights two to
five times a week I guarantee you'd be
in great shape
alright I don't want to be a [ __ ] but
you just basically described what
everybody already knows yeah if you work
out two to five times a week and go for
an hour hike every day or 30 minutes a
day um but the thing is you also have to
switch up you got to switch it up you
know or else your body gets used to it
then that's the worst part cuz then
you're you're working out and you're not
seeing any gains that whole muscle
confusion thing you know what I really
think about all this stuff is basically
whatever works for you whatever works
for you um here's another twist on the
advice but I appreciate the advice
everybody I'll take anything I can get
as I slide into my 50s advice update um
here was the original question said Bill
I need some help I'm a 25 year old dude
from Jersey and I've been with my
girlfriend for six and a half years I
asked you to marry me in April and she
said yes great right not so fast
she said she's a special ed teacher oh I
remember this she wanted you to move she
was having a tough time getting a
full-time job she took an interview in
Virginia right outside DC and surprise
surprise she got it she took the job and
is living with a friend down there it
kind of blows we always see each other
on the weekend I'm currently a paralegal
at a firm in New York and was
considering law school but I've started
to lean towards not going seeing how
lawyers are miserable douchebags I'm not
really a career guy but I don't want to
start over a new place we talked about
me moving there but I want I don't want
to leave because I'm a Northeast elitist
but she's also talking about moving back
after a year which would be next
September what should i do should I move
to the [ __ ] Confederacy or stick it
out and see if she's going to move back
I forget what I told him I basically
said he you know how motivated are you
she might be just saying this to get you
to move down there and then she's got
you down there then you're legally
married then you're [ __ ] so here's the
follow up but but anyways says well it
looks like I'm moving in a few months
he's going to Virginia I visited a
couple weeks ago and really liked it
there
conditions we have breed upon one is
that it's not it's not permanent oh
Jesus
checks in the mail buddy and two I do
not have to make friends I'm going to
take this opportunity to go to graduate
school and get my masters in Library and
Information science what the [ __ ] is
that you're gonna be a librarian it's
all going on the internet dude what are
you doing he said I know I know it's
kind of gay but I enjoy reading and
research so I figure I might as well
make a career out of it thanks for the
advice you know what dude I think you're
doing the right thing you know you don't
want to be some [ __ ] yeah you're not
you're not some pit bull gonna go in
there and fight it out with other
lawyers you like chilling you know there
you go
speaking of bums this guy's gonna go
down there and become a librarian you're
a bum
get a [ __ ] job no I'm kidding
whatever if it makes you happy go ahead
and do it
all right plowing ahead here you know I
started this podcast three times I can't
even remember if I even talked about NFL
football you know but big shout-out to
[ __ ] Brandon Jacobs for saying what
the [ __ ] I've been saying about Rex Ryan
for the last three years all right and I
got I'd actually gone past being annoyed
by Rex Ryan and I actually I still don't
want him to win but I feel bad for that
guy that guy is got like a giant
truckload of self-sabotage you could
just see it it's really getting like
cringe-worthy I can't even say that cuz
it's still too early cuz I don't even
think that the [ __ ] did I already
talked about this I can't even remember
I don't [ __ ] remember all I know is
that thing is gonna go one way or the
other that guy hit guy is going for
broke he's either gonna make it to the
promised land or he is gonna do the
biggest belly flop he ever saw off the
George Washington Bridge he might take
out a tugboat or two god bless him man I
hope that that guy puts his demons to
rest
look anyway so let's fly ahead here plow
ahead alright advice for the week bill I
need some advice and I think you're the
one to kick me in the ass on this
alright about a year ago I got involved
with this lady at work who I had been
crushing on for a couple of years
everything was great was as great as I
dreamt it would be and I couldn't have
been much happier except one caveat she
was engaged and he writes here oh Jesus
my god dude oh Jesus I can't even judge
you you know who hasn't been there you
know
oh god this girl was in an abusive
relationship oh my god dude [ __ ] that
you know what you're in right now dude
you're in a [ __ ] drag racer the
engine is caught on fire and you're
starting to do that zigzag while you're
trying to keep it in control the shoots
already come out but you're still gonna
slam into the wall though the leaf
ejection button now oh god this has
[ __ ] double homicide suicide written
all over it this girl was in an abusive
relationship even coming into work with
a broken finger one day so any sympathy
I may have had for the guy went out the
window I fell in love with this girl
dude
what's wrong with you this is damaged
goods you should [ __ ] take this girl
to go get some help so she can work out
a childhood issue that she's gonna stick
around with a guy like this she said she
loved me and I was convinced she was
gonna call off the wedding she can't
call off the wedding this guy's [ __ ]
breaking her fingers dude this is
[ __ ] creepy man
you need dude [ __ ] what you want to do
you need you need to either help this
girl out get her some help or report
this [ __ ] dude he broke her finger what
kind of a [ __ ] animal could do that
can you imagine [ __ ] doing that
what a [ __ ] animals anyways he goes
we all know how this story ends however
she stays with the douchebag and I'm
left brokenhearted
alright well lesson learned buddy you
know I'm not trying to blame the victim
here but the kind of person that would
stay with somebody like that
you know they have issues any girl with
some self-esteem you know with
confidence the first time a guy does
some [ __ ] like that it's [ __ ] over
it's over you don't stick around and say
yes to getting married and all that this
girl needs help and I got to tell you
dude if you want to get a quickest way
to get in a broken heart is to fall in
love with damaged goods why don't you
just go [ __ ] look for your soul mate
in a titty bar
alright I'm being a little harsh let me
just let me read the rest of this
anyways I obviously stopped talking to
her and even though I occasionally saw
her in the office it wasn't like we had
we had to talk since we worked in
different areas so it was semi tolerable
being a selfish [ __ ] though she kept
trying to contact me she's not being
selfish she's [ __ ] damaged and I
finally relented a few weeks ago and we
even made out after the Christmas party
ah dude the same way she stays in that
relationship and goes back for more
you're doing the same thing you know
what you both need to go to therapy oh
my god dude the drag racer has hit the
[ __ ] wall you know now you're laying
upside down in your fire suit as the
flames of lapping at your toes and
you're waiting for some fat [ __ ] with a
fire extinguisher to come down there and
that's who I am I'm running down the
track buddy hang in there let me read
the rest of this and let's see if we can
get you out of this till we make out at
the Christmas party was her [ __ ]
husband there talking for hours alone
afterwards or was he already drunk and
trying to [ __ ] somebody else you work
with anyways she still claims to love me
and says how we are perfect and that she
knows I'm the one she should be with but
can't leave
all right that sounds like there's a
firearm involved complicating matters is
she has some health issues that are
potentially serious and she worries
about not having time to start over let
me get this straight you fell in love
with somebody with a terminal disease
who's engaged to somebody who breaks her
fingers and you still need advice you
know what sometimes you do when your
hearts involved maybe you just need to
hear me say your scenario out loud
anyways he goes part of me is
sympathetic for asking her to flip her
life upside down part of me hates her
for not just letting me go and move on I
recently told her to leave me alone but
I'm a weak man when it comes to her
please help me out and set me straight
sorry if this was long but I felt all
the details were necessary love the
podcast thanks ya dude I've already
given it to you
yeah dude you need to work on your
self-esteem you're telling me you know
that you can't find something but you
can't find a better situation than this
you know your biggest problem dude is
not gonna be walking away from this
situation because there's only so many
times she can stick your [ __ ] balls
in a vise okay before you you know no
matter what you're just gonna walk away
from this girl there's no [ __ ] way
you're gonna end up with this girl but
what you need to make sure is that you
don't repeat this because there's
something [ __ ] up with you that you
gravitated towards this girl that you
need to address how about we do this
next time around okay no more girls who
were engaged okay no more girls who come
in with a broken collarbone in a chip
tooth because they quote-unquote walked
into a door 17 times let's try and stay
away from them yeah the next time you
see an abused woman let's why don't you
try and get her some help
rather than [ __ ] her on the copier
dude you need to get you need to work on
yourself all right
sit down and write a list of what you're
looking for in a mate all right and
can guarantee you engaged to someone
else won't make the list broken finger
from fur person she's engaged with I bet
coworker won't even be in there dude
you need an oasis you got to get away
from people you know you know I mean Nia
get along so [ __ ] great cuz I go on
the road twice a month get the [ __ ] out
of here read I can't look at your
goddamn red beard anymore all right so
that's what I would do
worst thing you can do now is rebound
and just get into another relationship
and use another human being cuz you
don't want to be lonely you you plow
through that loneliness sir all right
all the money you'd spend breaking some
other girl's heart because you don't
want to be alone to spend that on get a
sports package join a [ __ ] gym you
know there's gotta be something that you
always wanted to [ __ ] do and you
never did it here's one once you go to
the Pro Bowl this year all that money
you would have blown on some other
[ __ ] broad why don't you go to Hawaii
and go to the [ __ ] Pro Bowl show up
there and some Robin Williams [ __ ] why'd
why not go out there and try to [ __ ]
some Honolulu [ __ ] what are you ever
gonna get to do that again just [ __ ]
do it that I know you who who's gonna
cost me serving on a book you get spent
seven hundred bucks on some broad
between Thanksgiving and Christmas
anyways do one for yourself alright do
something like that go have a good
[ __ ] time alright and just really
meditate on what the [ __ ] you looking
for and stay out of something like this
god damn what a piece of [ __ ] break
somebody's breaks their goddamn finger
alright anyways plow ahead I want that
one was depressing
number two bill I'm 19 years old and
I've been training in Taekwondo since I
was about 11 and teaching since I was 17
that's [ __ ] awesome between
tournaments college and teaching I don't
really have a lot of time for other
things however I'm no pie baking fair
and I'm still I like making pies go [ __ ]
yourself anyways and I still get time in
for the ladies
when I can there is one chick I'm
talking to now and believe me when I say
she's a perfect believe me when I say
she's a perfect ten great body beautiful
face funny personality and an actual
goddamn brain in her head anyways we've
been talking for a little bit and things
were going great I only just met her
through my cousin a couple of months ago
however about two months ago I noticed
she was acting a little bit more
distance oh Jesus than usual and I
couldn't really tell if she was
interested anymore I'm not trying I'm
not really the guy to pry so when she
wasn't texting me I said [ __ ] it and
ignored her for a few days that's
actually a good move in the spirit of
the great chemistry we had I continued
to try and connect with her sending her
a tech once in a while and I still
couldn't shake the feeling that
something was up you got to listen to
your gut dude what does she go back to
her ex-boyfriend um so I asked my cousin
who introduced us to see if she had told
her anything turns out she's actually
talking to another boy whom she likes
more than me but didn't know how to tell
me because she thinks I'm really cool
and she felt bad because she's been
acting differently around me but she's
been talking to this other guy for
longer oh Jesus
when I heard this I thought that [ __ ]
sucks but whatever there's nothing I can
do about it so I went to her and told
her I felt as though she had been acting
distant and I felt I wasn't getting the
same vibe from her sorry my computer
just crapped out anymore she told me
yeah she realized she really liked me
just not in the way but she thinks I'm
really cool aka I was put in the friend
zone [ __ ] she never mentioned to me
anything about the other boy she's just
trying to be nice anyway sir is there is
there nothing else I can do in this
situation usually I would say [ __ ] it
cuz I know there's no there's so many
other girls I could bang especially when
traveling for tournaments but like I
said this is something special I just
wanted your advice um yeah dude walk
away walk away just walk away you got
you got a great chance that this guy's
gonna be a douche bag treat her like
[ __ ] and eventually come back to you but
in the meantime you got to get on with
your life
she's being honest with you and she's
like so [ __ ] nice she doesn't want to
hurt your feelings and all she's gonna
do is just grab your heart rip it out of
your chest
hold it up and then throw it back at you
not it just trying to be nice you really
even though you think you're being nice
you're not being nice when you don't
want to be with somebody you should just
[ __ ] end it all right and it's gonna
suck and end it and then when you end it
you shouldn't try and reconnect with
them so you got it you know [ __ ] dude
you're a fighter protect yourself at all
times okay if somebody kicked you were
right in the [ __ ] face would you walk
back up to it with your arms down at
your side
you wouldn't alright that's it walk away
walk away you know it seems like it's so
early on in the [ __ ] relationship
that this this one you know within three
weeks believe me you're gonna find
another one and do it at the end of the
day she's into this other guy more than
you there's nothing you can do about it
the worst thing you can do is keep
pursuing her because then she's gonna
[ __ ] hate you so my advice is to just
[ __ ] leave it alone leave it alone
walk away move on you know bang some
other chick at a karate [ __ ]
tournament you'll find someone else you
young all right last one bill I'm 23
year old virgin when you say steer the
conversation towards sex do you mean the
topic do you like do you mean Jesus
Christ this guy's so [ __ ] hard up he
can't even finish the goddamn sentence
without writing it do you mean as the
topic of conversation or physical sex
what yeah I'm talking conversation here
dude why would I be saying physical yeah
I'm not saying just grab her tits at the
bar just yes steer the conversation look
23 year old virgin is something a little
bit different than I'm just talking
about how to go in a bar and [ __ ] a girl
and not get not get sucked into a
relationship all right that's what I was
talking about in that other podcast what
I would do you're a 23 year old virgin I
would you got to get out there you got a
hit on everything that [ __ ] moves
do not get sucked into a relationship
all right
because after 23 years or not [ __ ]
anything you're gonna be so goddamn
excited when you finally [ __ ] something
that you're gonna stick with somebody
that you're really not into you're just
so excited it'd be like if you walked
every day 20 miles to work and then one
day somebody finally gave you a piece of
[ __ ] car you have no idea it's a piece
of [ __ ] you're so [ __ ] excited you're
not walking anymore
you know so just talk a bunch of [ __ ]
wear a condom and like I said you're not
even at the point of steering it towards
sex just start [ __ ] talking to him
all right and every dumb thought that
you have that your brain says don't say
that just [ __ ] say it
I'm not saying be rude or be mean but
you gotta have a [ __ ] you just don't
give a [ __ ] all right here's a good one
rub one out before you go up give
yourself a little swagger okay just get
out there talk some [ __ ] Larry why don't
you just start with making out with a
girl let's just go easy you know just
just do that all right I don't you know
it's hard for me to give you advice coz
I don't know what you've been doing up
to this point but let's just start with
first base and then we'll move to second
base then third and then you're gonna
come you know you get thrown out at the
plate a couple of times and then you'll
[ __ ] could finally bang one then you
become an animal like everybody else you
won't even need this podcast anymore
all right overrated underrated for the
week overrated sideboob call me crazy
but I'm not a big fan of the side boob
even though it's as a considerable level
of popularity dude how do you not like
that side boob is so much better than
cleavage yeah it's so much rarer it's
like that yellow diamond that kobe
bought mrs. what's-her-face Brian
overrated ancestry people take too much
pride in their ancestors country their
cultural background etc from what I
noticed this happens to me a lot when
round the holidays because my family is
Italian for example my family is Italian
because my great grandmother came over
on the boat that's right
so I'm Italian even though I lived in
Amer
all my life and none of my family has
been there since my great-grandparents
came over here my friends tell me I have
a good taste in food like fish and have
an Italian personality I understand some
traditions carry on through various
cultures but how exactly does being a
white kid from the suburb who likes
grilled Sam salmon make me Italian I've
never been within 100 miles of Italy I
don't know one word of the Italian
language if you blindfolded me and drop
me off in Italy I would probably have a
panic attack and feel totally lost my
point is I'm American I'm from America I
developed my interest two things which
pertain to American culture that I grew
up in I get what you're saying I get
what you say but having said all that
dude you know you should know where
you're from and there's a lot of great
traditions you know my girl was watching
on one of those Real Housewives shows
you know with all the horrific plastic
surgery in the make up and then one of
the Italian families out in Jersey with
the rioting all over the clothes and the
hair up to the [ __ ] ceiling oh they
they did they do this thing that I
actually saw Mario Batali do which i
think is the coolest [ __ ] thing ever
is I have totally respect the Italian
culture in its they make them it's the
best food on the [ __ ] planet and the
level with which they give a [ __ ] about
food compared to my German Irish roots
is I'm so [ __ ] envious of it it's
ridiculous
so a lot of German Irish people out
there you have no idea like me when
anything is in season what vegetables
like I guess like carrots and [ __ ]
peas or something or in season I don't
even know but all I know as far as
Tomatoes those things are in season like
sometime over the summer
those things are in season and the rest
of the year what you're getting is some
spray-painted red horse [ __ ] from some
corporate farm and they taste like ass
so these Italians they grow their own
[ __ ] tomatoes and I'm watching this
[ __ ] and I don't know what they do they
stay state start to cook them and then
they blanch them and then they peel the
skin off and they stick them in a jar
these airtight jars so that they can
make fresh pasta sauce their red meat
sauce or whatever that tomato sauce for
the entire [ __ ] year and I just think
that it's the coolest [ __ ] thing ever
I was like I want to I want to learn how
to do that any Italians listening to
this [ __ ] I want to learn how to do that
I can't do it now cuz it's not this but
I would love to do that is that [ __ ]
weird I don't know like so I I get what
you're saying I get what you're saying
like everybody you know kiss me I'm
Irish and it's like dude you're from
Western Massachusetts okay you're from
Worcester you know you're not Irish you
never been to Ireland I totally
understand what you're saying but
there's a lot of great things you know
it's like anything there's a lot of
great things here there's a lot of great
things over there and if you combine the
two you gotta you got yourself a great
life all right that's it let's plow
ahead dilemmas hey Bill would you rather
be a lawyer or a doctor I know a lot of
people hate lawyers but doctors have
insane work schedules that impact the
amount of time they get to spend with
their families I'd much rather be a
lawyer you know you get to talk [ __ ] in
front of a crowd you know you get to put
your one foot up while your other hands
in your soup pocket you're rubbing your
balls you know talking to a jury who
wouldn't want to do that I don't [ __ ]
digging a bunch of goddamn cadavers I
totally respect doctors but you know
speaking of which what's what's the name
of that dead [ __ ] doctor show it's
basically that Ted Danson show Becker
except he's a doctor he's this grumpy
ass goddamn doc doctor bones or whatever
the [ __ ] it's called was that the guy
from Star Trek I've never seen that show
but that show [ __ ] annoys the [ __ ]
out of me
you know and recently they did this
episode where he goes to prison and he's
still being this [ __ ] tough talking
douche bag and all these prisoners are
listening to him this little runt
you know did he was like he wasn't
enough of the badass doctor because he
was this grumpy douche at the hospital
they stuck him in a prison and he starts
running
there that's well what kind of an
[ __ ] would watch that show anyways
let's go with the dilemmas here let's
let's close this out and that'll be the
podcast for the week okay bill would you
rather have unprotected sex with a girl
you love and want to marry who has
herpes and risk probably getting it in
order to conceive a child or would you
rather get dumped by a girl you love and
have to go through an awful awful
breakup finding a new place to live
constantly checking your phone to see if
she called filling up the time I'm too
selfish I'm gonna take the break broken
heart and no herpes soon I don't want
herpes who wants herpes you know what it
is because when you're in love with
somebody you have ups and downs you have
periods where you really love them and
then you have other periods where you
sit there going why the [ __ ] did I ever
get with this person so to go through
those down periods of going why the [ __ ]
did I ever get with this person while
having herpes sores on my dick would be
too much for me I'm gonna tap out and
I'm gonna roll the dice I'm gonna pull
the bill belichick I'm gonna trade away
my number-one draft pick and hope that
there's uh there's there's a diamond in
the rough and the sixth route in my 40s
all right dilemma number three all right
bill you're both swimming towards a both
you and Nia or some other lady there is
a shark following you I've actually
thought about this oh Jesus and only one
of you is going to get time enough to
get in the boat do you climb in and turn
around to see your girl getting eaten
alive or you stay in the water and help
push her in and get eaten yourself it's
not a huge shark so it won't be over
fast oh you [ __ ] [ __ ]
but it's big enough that after a few
chomps on your pasty white flesh you
down a few limbs at least no and I could
never watch Nia get eaten
but my wanting to survive would also
kick in so I think we both get eaten
because I would grab her by the arm ago
let's go let's go I'd be trying to do
that I couldn't live with myself if I
let her get eaten I I'd have to swim in
front of the shark I'd have to do it I
would [ __ ] punch that [ __ ] uh
who's kidding who I would freeze up yeah
uh you'd hear me screaming you'd hear me
screaming forever the [ __ ] you were at
oh that's one of my biggest [ __ ]
nightmares I've actually fantasized I'm
actually not fan it's like thought about
that [ __ ] seeing someone I loved in the
water and I'm on the boat and I'm seeing
a shark right on the surface and I
thought what I would do was I would time
it like you throwing somebody a [ __ ]
goddamn post pattern I would jump off
the boat feet first and land right on
the shark's head right before it bit
whoever I loved and it would so freak
the [ __ ] shark out like where the
[ __ ] did that come from that when it
regrouped I'd be able to push the person
in and then drag myself in the boat but
in in the fantasy I always still get my
legs bitten off because I'm so terrified
of it that was a good one
would you rather jump the subway tracks
in a moped rich Voss builds the ramp or
have Robert Kelly try and shoot an ample
an apple off your head with a crossbow I
got to go moped it's the train coming
how the [ __ ] would I get across the
subway with all that [ __ ] in them and I
would still do that I get a helmet right
it has nothing to do with the fact that
rich Voss builds the ramp it has to do
with the fact of Bobby Bobby would have
to hit me on a some level with the arrow
because he says he's a sadistic son of a
[ __ ] and the temptation and how much
I've annoyed him is no matter how much
that dude loves me the amount that I
have annoyed him of 20 years of our
friendship he would have to have it
graze off my forehead
so I would definitely I would jump the
subway tracks yeah but that would be
impossible cuz you know what you'd have
to do because the subway platform is so
shallow that I would have to be going
lengthwise and then try to cut the wheel
as it and then all my momentum would be
gone
I probably land on the third rail yeah
[ __ ] that I go out Evel Knievel style
land on the third rail and just [ __ ]
have to have him shut down an entire
[ __ ] subway platform I would do that
rather than sit there with a [ __ ]
arrow through my head like Steve Martin
reversed Steve Martin [ __ ] that [ __ ]
that alright that's the podcast for this
week everybody I hope you guys enjoy
your time off and you know and be
patient with your loved ones you know I
know that annoying the [ __ ] out of you I
know they are that's why I don't go home
for the holidays but if you are try to
find the humor and how [ __ ] crazy
they are that's my own that's my last
bit of advice because I've made those
[ __ ] mistakes that's it once again
everybody if you want to buy something
on amazon.com go to Bill burr com click
on the podcast and then click on
amazon.com like I said a percentage of
whatever you spend I'll you know I'll
get you know some trinkets for that and
then 10% of that will go to the Wounded
Warriors Project you know helps keep the
podcast going and it helps the wounded
veterans and you go out and get yourself
the turtleneck you really want it you
really can't miss it alright you can't
miss with that one that's the podcast
for this week Happy New Year everybody
go [ __ ] yourselves don't take any [ __ ]
and I'll talk to you next week
see
you